we have to talk about that exit did you
always have that plan or was it last or
was it a last-minute decision
um
it was kind of planned in the fact that
i'm not a hugger i did not want to hug
people on my way out the door i've had
to hug a lot of people throughout the
summer so i didn't really want that fake
kind of oh i love you so much it's okay
and just being the double everything
happened so fast i really didn't
want to say goodbye necessarily
i kind of wanted to have a little bit of
a dramatic moment
so i saw the opportunity i took it and i
got to avoid giving awkward hugs so
it is what it is
you broke janelle's veto record as a
super fan what does that mean to you
it is absolutely crazy to me to know
that i hold this record now
um i love and adore janelle so the fact
that you know she held this record
before me it you know it's a big honor
as a super fan i never expected to come
into the game and perform as well as i
did in these competitions i was more
worried about not going home the first
week so it never even crossed my mind
that this could happen for me but i'm
very honored to hold this record
why didn't you express your concerns
about kyle's comments sooner do you
regret that
i do regret not saying something sooner
i think
by the time it was very clear what he
was saying to me
it was end of week six and then we were
split up into
our different houses coming back in week
eight i
never felt like there was a good time to
share this information and looking back
no matter when i would have shared this
information
there's never a good time to say
something like this and i understand
that people are skeptical
about my decision and when we revealed
it
ultimately i felt like at the time it
was the right thing to do and the longer
that went by without saying anything the
worse that i felt and i knew that there
was never going to be just a golden
perfect time to say anything so
i tried to do the best with the
information that i had and to bring
things up at the right time i understand
that people view it as
maybe that it was trying to be
self-serving for my game no matter what
information you bring forward in the
game people are going to look at it how
is this benefiting you so i completely
understand
why people may feel that way
it never felt like a good situation and
hearing how it affected everyone and how
they wish it had been handled i do wish
i would have said something sooner and i
do regret that if you could do it over
would you have nominated a turner why or
why not
uh if i could go back in time i still
would have
not put turner up um i think that on
paper that looks like the move i should
have made but ultimately when turner
took out kyle who was
uh final two deal with i understand that
that wasn't good for his game and that
was something that turner did
you know to do what he felt was right
and i did not want the message here to
be that if you do the right thing you
should be punished for it or that doing
the right thing always has to come at
this great personal cost to yourself i
think it can exist where doing the right
thing also
can be the right thing for you as well
so i didn't want to turn around and do
that to him
it also makes it a little easier to
swallow i feel like i'd be sitting here
no matter what even if turner
had gone home last week i still think i
would have been evicted in the double so
i
can rest a little easier knowing that i
don't have as many what-ifs or what it
could have showed us
from that perspective as well so
ultimately i would make the same
decision again
who is next who is the next person you
hope is sent to the jury house
um on a petty level i would love to see
turner come through next since he
uh definitely
broke a promise to me and i felt like
you know he used the fact that we were
both part of the lgbtq plus community as
a manipulation tactic which i love and
respect this game so bold gameplay
strategic moves i can respect
bringing in some of that outside stuff i
not quite sure how i feel about it quite
yet uh so for that reason i would maybe
like to see turner but i do respect the
game um and understand that he is a big
player in the game right now so
from that perspective as a fan i think i
would like to see him go further but i
love and respect everyone left in the
house so it's gonna be
bittersweet no matter who walks in after
me